foreign
[Applause]
it's only been two years or so into the
new decade but if there's one thing that
anime never disappointed is giving us
encounters and battles to remember it's
these fights that most people love and
it's these fights that help anime
continue its surge of popularity into
the mainstream so for today I'm going to
be going over 10 of my favorite fights
from the years 2020 to 2022 and for an
added challenge I'll be limiting my
options to only new anime for those
years you ready
good
Ness
akudama Drive was the surprise of the
Season its high octane action with a
flash of sci-fi edginess and Mayhem the
chaos is quite fitting considering the
state of the world in those parts of
2020 it felt like it was yesterday when
anime fans were getting dazzled by the
action and intensity of this original
anime it shines in how it Revels in the
craziness and this fight is a shining
example of that the two characters brawl
in a game center blitzing through the
place and delivering Furious blows to
one another you see a lot of wild
moments like structures being thrown and
No Holds Barred beatdowns all in a span
of just two minutes the whole thing
feels more like a dance where the two
are having the time of their lives
overall it's a nice fight that more or
less captures the essence of what
akudama Drive is akodama Drive is no way
represented by fights alone but it's
this kind of frantic action and vintage
feel that really helped it stand out
amongst its peers in the fall of 2020.
[Music]
next is Team Ruby versus Nevermore
here's something from a new show on the
Block it's been a few episodes and I
think the ice queendom has generally
left a good impression on me I really
love major fights that showcase Team
Dynamics and this one is an early
example of that as a standalone flight
it's pretty good it does a good job of
letting the characters play their roles
in the team while they're working
together defeating the enemy using their
combined strengths it does feel extra
satisfying to see the battle end in
their Victory it's quite a nice fight
and it could be a good way to get people
to check out ice queen them it could be
recency buyers that made me put this up
here but I do think the ice queen them
has been a satisfying anime version of
the popular series so far it's good to
watch as a standalone but I think it's
even better to watch as a fan who can do
some comparing and contrasting between
the original and this one
foreign
[Music]
cats Legends Final Fight
[Music]
yes it's been a while since I talked
about Chinese anime but we have a great
one here why cat Legend is a pretty fun
and underrated show that aired during
the early part of 2020 it unsurprisingly
went under the radar like a lot of other
non-japanese shows but it's got some
epic fights like this one right here for
this fight I just love how smooth and
Sleek everything looked the transitions
just seemed so seamless and it's quite
creative in its approaching animation I
also like the pacing of the fight how
the characters shift from armed combat
to hand to hand and then right back all
while more and more things get added to
the fight to keep things from becoming
redundant it may not be the special
effects Fiesta the studios like UFO
table may have gotten used to but in
terms of honest effort-filled animation
this one's definitely right up there a
good finale for an underrated show
foreign
we then proceed to Boss versus budgie
talk about David versus Goliath we've
come to know ranking of Kings as a story
of an underdog rising to the top but no
fight in the series exemplifies that
concept as blatally as this and it also
does a damn good job of showcasing part
of why people have come to love ranking
of Kings bigger isn't exactly better
when you've got someone like boji whose
claim to fame is his amazing Speed and
Agility the fight itself may not be some
insane sarkuga Fest but I really love
how it makes the audience feel like
they're part of it the camera angles and
movement really capture what it's like
to be budgie trying to scale this
Titanic opponent in order to deliver the
finishing blow it's a fight that takes
the audience along for the ride and I
really love how that further enhances
what's already been a good fight don't
let the shortness of this fight I mean
it's just a little over a minute for you
because it's a minute or two of some of
the best fight directing we've seen in
the past two years or so
foreign
before reaching the halfway mark we take
a look at Destiny versus Orpheus
tagged on Destiny had a lot of big names
behind it and by the end of it all it
was overall a satisfying ride that gave
me more than I asked for in a mobile
game anime the story is straightforward
but it is also enjoyable and it's mostly
due to its presentation there's just a
joy to be found in playing climactic
battles in mobile games and this fight
just embodies that same feeling the
villain attacks are frantic and the
heroes find themselves in a Race Against
Time to defeat a seemingly unbeatable
foe pick you even get the Reviving boss
that comes back stronger only to be
beaten by the good guys with renewed
resolve I just like how this ended not
with powers but a good old bare-handed
thrashing if anything the fight captures
the food of what it's promoting and for
me that's a job well done tactdob
Destiny isn't exactly a masterpiece of a
show something to be talked about for
years to come but for what it is it's a
very fun watch and while it had so many
chances to become a disastrous game
adaptation that made no sense whatsoever
it rose up and became a show that we can
all enjoy
foreign
oh and if you're enjoying this video so
far and somehow aren't subscribed yet
then what are you waiting for go hit
that subscribe button and make the teams
day it won't take long and you can even
ring the bell to be the next in line for
our next video alright that's enough for
this break time to watch more exciting
fights since we talked about tacked up
already how about something quite
similar in field here's VB with its
astounding VV vs Hugo fight
tank top is all about the Sci-Fi girls
and the weapons explosions and
occasional brawling to create a
spectacle VV as a series takes its
fights in a slightly different direction
instead it chooses to wow our eyes with
some of the finest fight choreography
and camera work you'd get from a show
like this and amongst the many battles
the show has to offer I feel like I want
to feature the VV versus Hugo fight
today for a show that's as sci-fi as you
can get it's quite a pleasant surprise
to see Fighters meticulously crafted and
choreographed like this from their fall
to the eventual Close Quarters combat
when they land you get sucked into the
action through its excellent use of
stifle pacing and shots for added impact
there's quite a bit of bullet time going
on before having the fight shifter
frantic chaos overall I think the VBS
will show that people get into not
because of the action when they do get
into it fights Like These are nice
offers to give the show a little
something extra
what if you want to find a show with
fights as its main feature God of high
schooler is them
ironically people have been saying that
the people behind God of high school
focus too much on the fights to the
detriment of everything else I'm
inclined to agree so when it comes to
seeing the encounters between some of
the toughest tournament competitors they
better not disappoint thankfully Jin
versus Navy didn't disappoint in the
slightest this is in my opinion a fight
that's emblematic of what God of high
school has to offer it's got the
old-fashioned brawling it's got the
integration of Real World Martial Arts
into its technique and it caps
everything off with anime Powers
integrated in its Over the Top stances
oh and some great flashbacks to give a
chance for some reversal and add some
spice to characters in between the moves
too it pretty much is the quintessential
star for anime fights that feature a lot
of martial arts influence I liked it
back when it was being done in the 90s I
liked it when the star became prominent
in the 2000s and even in the present it
still holds up pretty well
Schwann versus wrath is next on the list
remember back when I was talking a lot
about fog Hill you don't I guess you
need to go back and check the 2020
videos and see how good this thing looks
fog Hill of five elements is a Chinese
anime that spans only three episodes but
it's pretty cool how there are already
multiple fights that could be considered
fight of the Year back when it was
airing it's largely due to how good it
looks the r star may seem simple but it
does have a unique Flair to it something
that makes everything look so distinct
and memorable then the characters start
moving and we get treated to some
astoundingly smooth animation I also
like the progression in the fight and
how it escalates over time it brings the
intensity in a way that you don't see
too much even in modern anime you know
the coolest part about this though fog
Hill is done by a rather small studio
and you can tell that even if there
weren't a lot of people involved in this
the people did put their all in this
project it's got animation that can go
toe-to-toe with your mappers and such
but with far few resources these guys
were also responsible for white cat
Legend which released a bit earlier and
you can tell why they haven't lost a
beat in fact they may have even got
better at it
foreign
can do with its fights
people don't immediately think of
intense fights when they think of
mushoku tensei they could think of its
influence in the isakai scene they could
think of the controversies they could
even think of how it's probably one of
the most complete issakai shows out
there with amazing world building but
this fight proves that in the action
Department it could hang with the big
boys fights serve a lot of purposes
sometimes they serve as the climax of an
arc or a way to build character at times
they just serve to let the animation
team Flex their might and at times they
serve to up the ante to build an
Unstoppable villain like what this one
did for orsted even after knowing the
result of the fight the whole sequence
was still a joy to watch with high
impact cuts and excellent voice acting
as each member of Team rudius Falls this
scene really brought the novel scene to
life while it's not as directly
immersive as the ranking of King's fight
it still does a pretty good job helping
the audience connect with what's
happening at the huge pinch team rudius
is in this fight did do a lot of things
right it showed our heroes in the most
precarious positions they've been in it
showed us how overpowered Allstate is
and it added an extra layer of tension
to the whole plot seeing rudius almost
dying was assigned I bet you didn't
expect to see now did you
best fight
this fight is no stranger to anime fans
who've been watching the hottest shows
of late and that's because it's just
that awesome Yuji and Toto versus Hanami
simply shows the best that Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen has to offer fast-paced fights a
good Showcase of powers some good back
and forth that makes a fight very
unpredictable and great utilization of
the two-on-one scenario the animators
got their work cut out for them in
helping this fight transition from manga
to anime and they pass the test with
flying colors this is a fight that takes
us through a lot of twists and turns
while letting both Yuji and Toto shine
another good thing about this fight is
how Gojo comes to end it with a
breathtaking finisher
and that's it for my list how does my
list compare to yours I think we're
gonna have some similarities but I'm
also very interested in hearing what
other fights you've got on your list if
you have something to share make sure to
chime in on the comments section with
your own list of 10 favorite fights if
you enjoyed the video don't forget to
check out the rest of the channel too
I've got a lot more videos and I'm sure
that if you like this one you'll
definitely at least like another one of
my lists as always feedback is always
welcome so you could also give your
thoughts on the format and the topics
through the comments section or in our
social media all the links are provided
in the description to come and connect
with the team that's all for this
edition of videotube lists I'll be
waiting for you all next time so make
sure to be there